whenever i see these lists of like the
greatest guests that ever did the david
letterman show they point to this
joaquin phoenix i thought that was
absolutely brilliant but again i could
imagine at the time you're saying to
yourself this kid's coming on i think
he's playing a character i don't know
unless he arranged it with you ahead of
time i don't know did he i knew uh what
he was doing
yeah did you enjoy him what he was doing
were you saying oh jesus oh no no i did
enjoy it because it was uh
you know like getting your work in on
the heavy bag you know it was just it
was easy it was it was batting practice
and uh joaquin i'm sorry you couldn't be
here tonight
the master of that of course was andy
kaufman i knew andy for years uh gosh he
was peculiar and and you and you just
loved it because
you sort of thought well this guy
uh is is wasting his life wasting his
career by being so peculiar right but
instead just the opposite happened by
being so peculiar he became an enormous
star the performer in you says i could
tell andy how to be great but meanwhile
andy was great doing what he did that's
right and and now um oh you know you
think about him had he lived
what what would he have done yeah
exactly what would he have done but he
was tremendous and and he uh was always
a gentleman to me
uh and always would let me know i'm
going to do
a b and c and and don't get upset when
the wrestler hits me oh you knew about
it yeah because i mean it looked
terrible
i mean it really looked like like you
were upset and when this guy jerry
lawler he didn't seem to be in on the
joke like he really smacked andy yeah
we're going to pause here for station
identification
[Applause]
[Music]
i thought andy got hurt and i loved andy
and it was like i was like oh my god he
just got hurt on the david letterman
show but what a [ __ ] show that was
right the best thing about it was the
next day or two days later in the times
the new york times the new york times
right writes this story up about andy
being assaulted on this talk show
and they refer to him of course their
editorial policy mr kaufman
and the wrestler mr lawler
and i just thought are you crazy you're
just why what are you wasting ink on
this uh and then the other thing after
each appearance he would lean over to me
and he said
be sure to send me the hate mail
he loved it i am sorry to use those
words on television i apologize
i'm sorry i'm sorry but you you're a
so did you see the real side of andy
kaufman i mean do you think you kind of
knew him and
no no i don't think so but but he was
he was courteous enough
to
include me he didn't want to exclude me
he didn't want to put me in an awkward
position so i was his ad hoc
partner in the bit i think i think you
can use some of those words on tv i
meant
but what you can't do is throw coffee
i've said it over and over again
sometimes uh like andy kaufman's manager
uh
bob zamuda right would come and hang
around the studio and we wouldn't know
it was that andy was it bob zamuta
it just was bizarre right and and but
you weren't annoyed by it were you oh we
loved it
oh my god yeah what's not to love andy
you take to take the night off and you
knew
something peculiar was gonna happen
you